حمله لبنانيه لردع الاعتداء الجنسي في بلد
تتهاون قوانينه في معاقبه المغتصب
العرض والشرف هاجس يمنع ستا من اصل 10
نساء تعرضنا للاعتداء الجنسي في لبنان من
التبليغ عن الجريمه ما يعني ان اكثر من
نصف نساء لبنان لم يبلغ
71% يعتبرنا ان المجتمع يرى ان الجريمه
بدرجه الاولى تشكل اعتداء على عرض العائله
قبل ان تكون اعتداءا ونفسيا على المراه
سنه 2022 يعني المراه صارت ضحيه ضحيه عم
يغتصبها وكمان ضحيه
القانون اللي ما عم يحميها
عيب على اللي عمله وبدها تحكي تنقدر نخلي
غير ضحايا ما يكونوا بذات الموقف عنا
ونقدر نلقى الشخص ما نخليه بالشارع قاعد
عم يمشي كانه ما صار شيء
الارقام هذه وردت في دراسه اجرتها منظمه
ابعاد الحقوقيه التي نجحت قبل اعوام
بالغاء ماده قانونيه كانت تعفي المغتصب من
العقاب في حال تزوج من ضحيته تحت شعار
الابيض لا يغطي الاغتصاب
وكان جرائم اعتداء على العرض او على العرض
او جرائم اعتداء على شرف اكثر ما هي جريمه
اعتداء على جسد المراه
وحريتها وارادتها ومن هون المطالبه بتشديد
العقوبات لا تصبح العقوبه بحجم جرائم هذه
جرائم كبيره ويجب ان تكون لديها بيت كبير
لمنع التكرار مثل جرائم وحمايه النساء
والفتيات
عقوبه بحجم الجريمه مطلب موحد جمع نساء
الناجيات من الاعتداء الجنسي وناشطات امام
مجلس النواب اللبناني تتوسطهم عارضه
الازياء والمؤثره اللبنانيه نور عريضه
للمطالبه بتعديل وتجديد العقبات على جرائم
الاعتداء الجنسي لصباح العربيه ريناد ويهي
بيروت
[موسيقى]
الهدف منه اقرار اقتراح تعديل جرائم
اعتداء الجنسي وتشديد العقوبات بحجم جرائم
مش العيب والعار انه يحكوا لعيبه العالم
ويكون في اغتصاب هيك وما يكون في عقوبه من
وراءها
[موسيقى]
دايما المجتمع بيحكم على المراه لانه عملت
هيك لانه لبست هيك
[موسيقى]